hello everyone for those of you who know
avoid boy this game is gonna be quite a
treat and those of you who don't know
who he is it's still a nice story of how
good things happen to people who play
chess now I've been playing League of
Legends since around season three since
the end of season two I haven't been
playing it that much for the past two
years I guess but before that I really
did enjoy a couple of games per day and
I don't know that was like five years
ago maybe maybe yeah five years ago you
know I was checking out some videos on
YouTube and I searched League of Legends
best place or something like that and it
was like the World Championship or
something and boy boy just did a double
kill in top lane with Olaf and it was
quite a spectacle you know everybody was
sharing that video so okay I decided you
know I'm interested in League of Legends
I'm gonna follow a boy boy and I
definitely enjoyed a lot of videos he
presented on YouTube and I also followed
a lot of his streams on Twitch and this
is one interesting event that happened
in one of his streams he was playing
league as usual and although avoid boy
did enjoy chess when he was younger he
also wants some trophies but I haven't
played actively in quite a while but he
started playing against his subscribers
you know while he waits in between games
and one of his subscribers offered him
$1,000 if he can defeat him and in a
game of chess and Robo agreed to do so
and they decided to play a game and this
is the game the game is being played
while the League of Legends a game is
getting ready to start so what has the
white pieces and he plays efore we had
e5 Knight to f3 d6 d4 and Knight to f6
we have D captures on e5 d characters an
ephod and here what were plays Knight
captures on e5 I'm a much better move
would be something like Queen captures
on D 18 captures and then you capture on
e5 grabbing a pawn also threatening the
f7 pawn to fork to the king and the rook
this would have been much better but
okay it's it's a two-minute game so to
two minutes per player no no no
additions in time yeah he's playing
against spooky shockwave spooky
shockwave is the person is the deaf
person's username and he's the one that
offered boy boy at $1,000 if he can beat
him so okay he played Knight captures on
e5
Queen captures on d1 and King capture
son d1 and now Knight captures on e4 so
the material is equal but now instead of
black not being able to Castle now
Berber is entitled to castle
Bishop to e3 Bishop to d6 attacking the
knight Knight back to f3 Bishop to g4
and Knight to c3 Bishop captures on f3 g
theatres on f3 and now Knight captures
and see a nun c3b captures on c3 and at
the end of this series of exchanges
avoid boy now has four pawn islands and
a pretty crippled pawn structure so
black black is much better here what he
does have in at least some compensation
is the bishop pair which is always
useful in an open game spooky shockwave
castles Bishop to d4 now b6 we had wrote
the g1 placing the roof on and open the
file and now f6 he could have grabbed a
pawn but like I said it's a two-minute
game and he wants to he wants to
diminish the influence of this dark
square bishop by placing these pawns on
a dark square but then again whoever
does have a light square bishop so you
know it's not really all that all that
simple h4 now since black didn't capture
a pawn what were decides to push it
c5 wouldn't attack on the Bishop Bishop
to d3 and rook to e8 now Bishop to b5
attacking the rook on d8 rook to e5 and
now Bishop to f4 and this Bishop to f4
moves seems like it seems like a void
Boyd the genius is creating an evil trap
for black rook to d5 check and black
falls for rook the d5 was actually as
terrible move and while I was watching
this game I thought man this this boy
but really really knows what he's doing
and here he played Bishop to d2 because
it seems that while life is checking the
white king is also attacking this
on f4 it seems like whoever will lose a
piece but what actually Webber could
have done here is play King to e2 and
now black is lost there is if you if you
capture the Bishop Bishop captures and I
fourth then Bishop to c4 comes you lose
the rook there is no way to defend the
rook and not only do you do you lose the
route but you also have to lose either
the night or the other Brook because
what do you want to play here if you
play something like Knight to c6 then
Bishop captures rook the king is in
check you're also attacking the knight
King to f8 and the bishop captures
knight on c6 and if you don't play
Knight to c6 if you play Knight to d7
then Bishop captures
King f8 and Bishop captures the other
rook on a eight so this would have been
this would have been great if boy boy
went for King e2 what okay he played
Bishop to e2 and then now Bishop to a
for spooky shock wave is now pinning
this bishop and getting ready to capture
it and here Bishop to d3 was played
again Bishop to c4 wins the game
straight away but it seems the ball boy
missed the idea of of Bishop to c4 like
I said it's a it's a two-minute game and
he's also wondering if his League of
Legends game started already Bishop to
d3 and our Bishop captures and e2 King
character son d2 and Knight to c6 see
for attacking the rook rook d4 and now
c3 kicking the rook rook to d7 now king
c2 unpinning so the bishop can move rook
a to d8 spooky shockwave now doubles up
on the D file and we have Robbie G to D
one night nine three five attacking the
bishop and now comes the bishop to d4
protecting the f3 pawn and offering the
exchange of rooks also setting up a very
nice trap
rook characters and v1 was played rukka
captures rook captures and keen captures
and although okay here I mean the
material is equal but Volvo now does
have a bishop against a knight and he
does have still these doubled pawns so
it's not I mean black is better here
because of the double spawns but it was
at this moment that war boy pressed alt
stab and the check checked his a League
of Legends game
he bought some items he was mid lane
with yeah so and he clicked on the
center of the map to go mid lane then he
went back to the chess game and in this
position
spooky shockwave played nine captures on
c4 and Volvo immediately seized the day
with Bishop to d5 check checking the
King and also attacking the knight and
now it's over
King f8 Bishop captures on c4 and I was
only a matter of technique and now Robo
shows his great endgame skills
King e7 King c2 now King d6 both players
are activating their King in the endgame
King e5 in III novel boy gains
opposition on the enemy King King f5 a
for now g6 f4 we have g5h captures F
captures and F capture screen captures
and now f4 check and whoever created a
passed pawn this pawn is now going to
become a queen king at five King to f3
again gaining opposition King of six and
now the king is coming into the game
King g6 King e5 King g7 King e6 h 7h six
that's a pretty weird move to play you
know you probably want to play h5 but he
missed clicked so h6 King e7 now came
back to g6 Bishop to e6 not allowing the
black King to get anywhere near this
passed pawn king h5 f5 King gauge for f6
king g v f7
king g6 and now f8 Queen in this
position void boy yield yes and he
realized that his times that his
opponents time has run out so he
achieved this great victory it was a
like I said a two-minute game so not a
lot of planning involved here and he's
not an active player or anything he just
enjoys an occasional game or two against
his subscribers and yeah he won this
game and spooky shockwave said before
the game that he will donate $1,000 the
boy boy but he has to give $500 to
charity
agree to these terms but after the game
spooky shockwave said that he was
currently on vacation and that he has no
means now to actually do the donation at
the moment but that he will do it later
now I have no idea if boy boy got those
$1000 it would be a shame if he didn't
but then almost a couple of seconds
after this an amazing thing happened
some some person on Twitch with a user
named Garry Kasparov donated five
hundred and fifty or five hundred and
sixty dollars to voyboy
saying that he didn't play this game
against him but that at least he wants
to donate half of the prize to him so
you know I don't know if I forgot those
1000 dollars that spooky shockwave
promised him but if he did and he got
those five hundred and something dollars
from a user named Garry Kasparov then
then it seems a voyboy who's a
professional league of Legends player
got over fifteen hundred dollars for
playing one two-minute game online in
between his games and that is more money
than professional chess players making
in in two minutes that is an insane
amount of money so yeah but that's just
my point you know he's a professional
league of Legends player he makes League
videos he streams league but it was only
when he played a game of chess did he
get $1,500 for playing a two-minute game
so like I said good things happen to
people who play chess so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed that I would
like to thank see movi henan and
sebastian button for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon